[Musique]
elles apprenaient le japonais et rêvait
d'enseigner l'anglais au japon oui ce
machin dame ali est morte il ya un an
dans un centre de l'immigration
japonaise après avoir demandé en vain
une aide médicale sa famille est venue
du sri lanka pour cette cérémonie
bouddhiste
je crois que l'âme de ma soeur n'est pas
apaisée
je vous demande à tous de prier pour
qu'elle puisse reposer en paix
je souhaite changer la loi pour que
cette tragédie ne se reproduise jamais
[Musique]
cette disparition a ravivé le débat au
japon sur les conditions de vie dans les
centres de détention pour étrangers
illégaux
les étrangers ne viennent pas au japon
pour mourir ils viennent pour y vivre
depuis 15 ans dix sept personnes sont
décédées dans des centres de rétention
quand which may est morte je me suis dit
ah encore ça ne m'a pas surpris en fait
la petite soeur de wisches masse est
installé à tokyo pour intenter un procès
contre les autorités arrivé au japon en
2017 pour étudier which may était resté
au delà de son visa d'étudiante
c'est la dernière photo qu'on a prise au
sri lanka juste avant son départ
j'ai pris un seul fille et je me suis
dit que c'était la dernière photo que je
pourrais prendre avant longtemps
c'est vraiment triste
après une demande d'asile refusée oui
sma est enfermé en 2020 dans un centre
aux allures de prison pas de limite
légale à sa détention elle perd 20 kilos
en quelques mois et se plaint d'avoir
mal à l'estomac ces gardiens prétendent
qu'elle ment
et dame je ne savais même pas que ma
soeur était détenue par les services de
l'immigration on ne nous a même pas dit
qu'elle était malade la raison pour
laquelle on va au tribunal c'est que ma
soeur était malade mais on ne connaît
toujours pas la cause de sa maladie un
rapport officiel a fini par reconnaître
des négligences médicales des excuses
ont été présentées à la famille des
responsables sanctionnés et des réformes
mises en place mais régulièrement les
centres de l'immigration japonais sont
pointés du doigt
malnutrition bastonnade comme dans cette
vidéo d'un détenu brésilien maltraités
en 2018
chaque année environ dix mille étrangers
déposent une demande d'asile au japon
moins d'une centaine seulement est
approuvé contre plusieurs dizaines de
milliers chaque année en france ou aux
états unis
bio et birmans ring à une minorité
musulmane persécutée au myanmar arrivé
en 2006 à l'âge de 20 ans avec une
petite valise sa vie n'a guère changé
depuis il est toujours en attente d'un
statut de réfugié et surtout il n'a pas
le droit de travailler résultat pour
survivre il fait le tour des
associations
des gâteaux des masques du pain je vis
juste avec ça en fait avec ce qu'on me
donne j'avais une image très positive du
japon je pensais qu'on allait m'offrir
un vrai statut
franchement si je revenais 16 ans en
arrière je ne viendrai pas ici
la troisième économie de la planète est
un pays vieillissant qui a d'énormes
besoins de main d'oeuvre et pourtant le
japon refuse de s'ouvrir à une
immigration de masse il ne veut pas
suivre le modèle occidental
résultat les étrangers présents sont
souvent en situation précaire une
immigration nier bien que réelle le pays
compte près de 3 millions d'étrangers
avant d'arriver au japon je ne pensais
pas qu'il y avait autant d'étrangers
dans le pays
tous les vendredis millau vient prier
dans cette cage d'escalier transformée
en mosquée avec d'autres virements des
indonésiens des pakistanais liberté
religieuse et sécurité les points forts
du japon selon lui
la birmanie c'est un pays dangereux où
on stigmatise les musulmans alors qu'au
japon je peux garder mon chapeau et
aller où je veux
cet ami rohingya s'est marié à une
birmane naturalisé il peut aujourd'hui
travailler et a ouvert cette boutique
c'est le rêve de beaucoup de demandeurs
d'asile trouver un emploi mais
l'administration à des règles strictes
elle accepte 1% parfois même moins des
demandes d'asile les candidats déboutés
ne sont pas renvoyés chez eux de force
certains sont en liberté provisoire avec
interdiction de travailler d'autres
détenus dans ces centres de la mort
comme ces manifestants les appels 7
burkinabé y a passé 15 mois
quand j'ai été arrêté
mon bébé avec à peine un mois on ne
m'autorisait à le voir qu'à travers une
vitre
je ne pouvais pas dans ces conditions
quand je suis sorti mon enfant ne savait
même pas qui j'étais
fin 2020 l'onu estimait que la politique
japonaise en matière de droit d'asile ne
répondaient pas aux normes
internationales des droits de l'homme
[Musique]